ORDERLY HUMANE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
WHY DON'T WE HAVE THAT ALREADY.
LET'S BRING IN SOUTH DAKOTA
GOVERNOR KRISTI NOEM TO TALK
ABOUT THE BORDER GOOD MORNING TO
YOU, GOVERNOR.
>> GOOD MORNING THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON YOUR SHOW.
AINSLEY: THANKS FOR COMING ON
BEAUTIFUL BACK DROP THERE OF
MOUNT RUSHMORE.
I KNOW YOU WENT DOWN TO THE
BORDER RECENTLY.
YOU'RE SENDING YOUR NATIONAL
GUARD OUT TO HELP IMPACTED
STATES AND YOU CALLED THIS
BORDER CRISIS A HUMAN
TRAGEDY, WHY?
>> IT IS.
I WENT DOWN THERE TO VISIT THE
MY NATIONAL GUARD.
I SENT ABOUT 48 SOLDIERS DOWN
THERE 30 DAYS AGO WE JUST
EXTENDED THAT ANOTHER 30 DAYS.
THEY ARE IN THE MOST CRITICAL
PART OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF TRAFFIC
KING OF HUMANS AND A LOT
OF TRAFFICKING OF DRUGS CROSSING
THAT'S IMPACTING OUR STATE AND
THE ENTIRE MIDWEST AND COUNTRY,
AND BESIDES WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL MORNING
AND THAT'S THE ILLEGAL ALIENS
COMING OVER THAT BORDER BY THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS, SO MY
GUARD WAS PERFECTLY SUITED FOR
THIS MISSION.
THEY ALSO WORK VERY WELL WITH
THE TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD AND
LOCAL BORDER PATROL BUT THEY'RE
ALARMED AS WELL AS I AM BY
WHAT'S HAPPENING DOWN THERE AND
HOW THIS FACILITATION OF
MIGRATION IS HAPPENING BY THE
WHITE HOUSE.
STEVE: SURE.
BRIAN:  YOU WERE CALLED OUT BY
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI BECAUSE STURGI
S IS EVIDENTLY
SOMETHING HE WASN'T INVITED TO.
IT'S PROBLEMATIC.
OUTDOORS ON A MOTORCYCLE, YOU
WOULD THINK BE ONE OF THE SAFEST
PLACES TO BE.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID ABOUT ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT EVENTS IN
YOUR STATE.
>> IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY WANT THEIR FREEDOM TO DO
THAT, BUT THERE COMES A TIME
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT COULD
INVOLVE YOU, YOUR FAMILY, AND
EVERYONE ELSE, THAT SOMETHING
SUPERCEDES THAT NEED TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
BRIAN:  GOVERNOR?
>> IT'S SHOCKING TO ME THAT HE
CONTINUES TO PICK ON REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, PEOPLE WHO LOVE THEIR
FREEDOMS, AND HE IGNORES WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
I DIDN'T HEAR HIM CRITICIZE
PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR HAVING A
PARTY FOR HIS BIRTHDAY.
I DIDN'T HEAR HIM GO AFTER THE
OTHER CONCERTS THAT HAVE
BEEN HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY
OR  THE COMPLETE IGNORING OF OUR
FEDERAL LAWS BY THIS OPEN BORDER
POLICY THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
EMBRACED.
DR. FAUCI HAS BECOME POLITICAL
AND I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE THERE'S GOING TO BE A
POINT IN TIME AGAIN WHERE WE
REALLY NEED OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND KNOW WE CAN TRUST
THEM AND HE HAS DISCREDITED HIS
ENTIRE PROFESSION BY THE
POSITIONS HE'S TAKEN DURING
THIS PANDEMIC.
STEVE: SURE AND THERE DOES SEEM
TO BE A DOUBLE STANDARD YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
HE TALKED ABOUT STURGIS, HE
DOESN'T TALK ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S BIG PARTY OR
LOLLAPALOOZA IN CHICAGO BEING
POTENTIAL SUPER SPREADER EVENT,
AND HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT THE
FACTS, AND APPARENTLY, A WEEK
AGO TODAY, JOE BIDEN GOT A
BRIEFING FROM HIS DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, AND WAS TOLD
THAT ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY, ILLEGALLY, HAVE
COVID.
THEY DON'T TEST EVERYBODY, BUT
THE ONES THEY TEST, A QUARTER
HAVE COVID WHICH IS UNBELIEVABLE
AND YESTERDAY, THE MAYOR OF LARE
DO, TEXAS SAID EVERYDAY,
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
COMING INTO THEIR TOWN, THEY'VE
GOT TO SPEND $10,000 A DAY TO
BUST THEM OUT AND NOBODY IS
TESTED, SO PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
LAREDO TEXAS, WE DON'T
KNOW IF THEY HAVE COVID AND THEY
GO TO AUSTIN AND HOUSTON AND
SOME PROBABLY WIND UP IN SOUTH
DAKOTA.
>> STEVE WHEN I WAS DOWN THERE,
I WAS JUST THERE FOR ONE DAY.
WE GOT A PHONE CALL I WAS WITH
THE BORDER PATROL AND MY
NATIONAL GUARD.
THEY GOT A PHONE CALL FROM A
LOCAL SHERIFF THAT SAID I'VE GOT
50 COVID POSITIVE ILLEGAL ALIENS
I'M HOLDING AT A LOCAL BASEBALL
FIELD.
WHAT CAN I DO WITH THEM AND
BORDER PATROL SAID I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THEM AND THEY
SAID WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPACE,
WE'RE FULL.
A NON-PROFIT THAT USUALLY TAKES
THESE INDIVIDUALS DIDN'T WANT TO
TAKE THEM BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL
COVID POSITIVE, AND THAT WAS
LITERALLY THE DISCUSSION THAT
OUR BORDER PATROL OFFICERS WERE
HAVING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE AS IN THEY'VE
GOT THIS CRISIS CREATED BY
SOMEBODY WHOSE THOUSANDS OF
MILES AWAY IN WASHINGTON D.C.,
AND EVERYDAY THEIR LIFE IS HELL,
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISIONS AND THEY
AREN'T GIVING THE AUTHORITIES TO
GO FORWARD AND TO REALLY DEAL
WITH IT AND DO THE RIGHT THING,
SO THIS IS A TRAGEDY.
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
WHAT THIS WHITE HOUSE IS DOING
IS TRYING TO DESTROY AMERICA BY
IGNORING OUR LAWS AND WE KNOW
FOR A NATION WITHOUT LAWS, A
NATION WITHOUT A BORDER, THAT
WE'RE NO NATION AT ALL AND SO
IT'S ALARMING TO ME WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT IT AND THE
HYPOCRISY OF HOW THEY GO
AFTER AND DR. FAUCI GOES AFTER
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS AND NOT
OTHERS, IT'S WRONG AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO WAKE
UP.
BRIAN:  I'LL LET YOU SEE IF HE
COMMENTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE THIS BIG
CONCERTS IN CENTRAL PARK IN NEW
YORK CITY, I'D LOVE TO SEE HIM
TAKE THAT ON BECAUSE HE SEEMS TO
LIKE RIOTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS.
>> WELL THE MOTORCYCLE BIKE
RALLY IS GOING GREAT.
WE'LL HAVE UP TO ABOUT A MILLION
PEOPLE IN SOUTH DAKOTA.
WE ALWAYS LOVE IT WHEN PEOPLE
COME AND SEE US AND OUR
BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY, AND ALL THESE
FOLKS THEY'RE PATRIOTS.
THEY LOVE THE FACT THEY CAN TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND GO
SPEND SOMETIME WITH PEOPLE THAT
THEY LOVE AND SO I ENJOYED GOING
ON A MOTORCYCLE RIDE WITH THEM
AND SPENDING TIME WITH THEM,
HAVING CHARITY AUCTIONS WE
PARTICIPATED IN.
ITS BEEN A GOOD WEEK.
AINSLEY: YOU ALLOW LEMONADE
STANDS THERE.
THE KID WHOSE FAMOUS FOR SERVING
THE BIKERS LEMONADE.
>> I WENT TO SEE WYATT AND HIS
FAMILY AND I WAS STANDING THERE,
THERE'S LINES AND LINES OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO DONATE TO ST.
JUDE, THIS LITTLE BOY HAD
ORGANIZED.
HE ALREADY HAD A DIRT BIKE
DONATED TO HIM, BUT THEY ARE
LINING UP AND THESE FOLKS ARE
GETTING OFF THEIR MOTORCYCLES
HANDING HIM $100, GIVING HIM A
HUG, AND THANKING HIM FOR
THINKING OF OTHER PEOPLE,
AND FOR RAISING MONEY FOR OTHER
PEOPLE.
SO THESE PEOPLE HAVE BIG HEARTS,
AND ARE THERE SUPPORTING A YOUNG
MAN WHOSE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
STEVE: LET'S TALK, GOVERNOR,
ABOUT A YOUNG WOMAN BY THE NAME
OF TYMARA STOCK.
TEAM USA WRESTLER, SHE WON THE
GOLD AND SAID THIS ABOUT A
WEEK AGO.
SHE SAID I LOVE REPRESENTING THE
U.S..
I FREAKING LOVE LIVING THERE.
I LOVE IT AND I'M SO HAPPY, I
GET TO REPRESENT USA.
SHE WAS ON WITH SHAWN LAST NIGHT
AND SAID THIS.
WATCH.
>> MY MOM RAISED US TO BE
RESPECTFUL AND MY DAD WAS AN
IMMIGRANT AND HE CAME FROM GH
ANA, CAME TO AMERICA AND
HE MADE A WAY FOR HIMSELF, LIKE
HE HAD A WHOLE BUNCH OF
BUSINESSES, AND HE MADE NOTHING
OUT OF SOMETHING OR  HE MADE
SOMETHING OUT OF NOTHING AND I
JUST KNOW THAT IF YOU GO OUT AND
GIVE WHAT YOU WANT, NOTHING CAN
STOP YOU SO I GUESS JUST FROM
THOSE KIND OF PARENTS IN MY LIFE
, I JUST HAVE LOVE FOR MY
COUNTRY.
STEVE: SHE HAS LOVE FOR HER
COUNTRY AND UNFORTUNATELY SHE'S
THE EXCEPTION.
WE DIDN'T HEAR THAT MANY U.S.
ATHLETES SAY I LOVE AMERICA
>> WELL HERE IS THE DIFFERENCE,
STEVE, THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT SHE LOVES HER
COUNTRY, SHE WAS RAISED WITH
CHARACTER, INTEGRITY, SHE HAS
GIFTS AND TALENTS.
SHE TALKED ABOUT HER FAMILY AND
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION WE NEED
TO START HAVING IN THIS COUNTRY
IS STRONG FAMILIES, THAT PARENTS
NEED TO BE PARENTS, THEY NEED TO
SPEND TIME WITH THEIR KID, IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH YOUR
CHILDREN SPEND TIME WITH THEM.
MAKE THEM BE WITH YOU, THAT'S
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TIME WITH
OUR CHILDREN ARE THE ONES THAT
INFLUENCE THEM, AND SO WE HAVE
TO START TALKING ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS IN THIS COUNTRY
STEM FROM FAMILIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING AND WE NEED TO START
BUILDING INTO THEM TO CREATE A
STRONGER ENVIRONMENT AT HOM